hey everyone its Johanna here today's
workout is designed especially for those
of you who are beginners and you would
like to start exercising and start
losing weight but you do not know where
to start and you just do not know how to
mix and match your own workout so my
advice for you is to follow this workout
for the next four weeks do it three
times weekly on every other day and
combine it with three times cardio as
well such as jogging swimming or even
cycling for best result when it comes to
quick and effective fat burning to lose
weight what you should be doing is total
body workout focusing on major muscles
in your body so this workout is going to
be focusing a lot on your legs because
that's the largest muscles in your body
your chest muscles your biceps triceps
shoulders as well as your back the way
to burn more calories is to increase
your heart rate therefore in every
workout you should be aiming to increase
your heart rate in order to burn more
calories and to burn more fats there
will be 10 exercises each exercise will
last for one minute 40 seconds workout
and 20 seconds rest do all 10 exercises
back to back without stopping once
you've completed the entire circuit rest
for one minute and repeat the entire
circuit 4 times so the total workout
will be 44 minutes 3 times weekly there
is no secret to losing weight it's 80%
nutrition and 20% exercise so clean up
your diet for best results you can
follow my food meal plan and be
committed to your workout stick by it
and I can assure you that if four weeks
time you will notice the difference
keep doing it keep progressing until you
have achieved your goal so let this be
the start to a new you when it comes to
working out you have to do your warm-ups
do at least 5 to 10 minutes warm up get
your muscles and your blood flowing this
will help to avoid any injuries and to
and a friend okay if you're a beginner
you can start by watching a sport or if
you find that this is too easy for you
they can always stop by just joking on
the spot five to ten minutes so I'm
going to put my timer on for two seconds
workout and 20 seconds rest and I'll be
guiding you through each regards all
right let's start the first workout is
jumping jacks okay so it's 40 seconds
remember to get at your own pace and
just breathe in and out okay find a
reason to your breathing because that
would really help with your workout so
no panicking no rushing just breathe in
and out and it really starts to feel
your lower body muscles working and
really reach all the way up to video
arms working as well okay and now rest
for 20 seconds the next one down is
push-ups so what we want to do is to
start on our knees try to keep your
knees together chest showed up with
apart okay and you go all the way down
and push off with your chest let's go
down Anna
so really squeeze your chest and push
all the way up same thing try to do as
many reps as you can within the forty
seconds as you progress you will find
that you will be able to do more rest
always remember to keep your back
straight tighten your core so no pump in
the air this is wrong if you're doing
this this is wrong keep your core tight
upper body in one line straight and push
up okay I was there
keep going you should be feeling your
chest your shoulders and your triceps
already at the same time good now rest
for 20 seconds the next workout is
called mountain climber this workout
will be focusing on your core at the
same time you will be working on the
upper bodies as well so get into a plank
position what you want to do is to
imagine that you're planning on the
mountain so bring your knees in close to
your chest and just keep climbing
alternate left to right okay so that's
like crunch it all the way in to be body
in a plank position and just climb as
you get as you progress week by week you
will be able to bring the speed up and
eventually bring it up to a rhythm okay
so this is really to work on your core
your legs and the other body at the same
time because the upper body is actually
supporting you get rest for 20 seconds
and the next workout our legs again
because our legs were really burning
help us to burn lots of fat the next
workout is alternate lunges so step back
what you want to be doing is to take a
wide step lunch down we divide straight
push back and alternate with your left
leg okay so simple you can keep your
hands by your hips push back I'll turn
it down and up
I say pushing back what you want to do
is to squeeze your pump at the same time
so this is a total body I mean the total
lower body workout there you go
okay try to keep your legs 90 degrees
good and what's that going you 90
degrees well done
and now just restful 20 seconds next
workout back to high knees because what
we want to do is to increase our hydrate
so simple then put it on up and just
jump up with high knees okay as high as
you can
this is to increase our heart will get
and when your heart rate goes up what
happens you burn calories all right so
trying to go as high up as a champ it's
fine if you can go too high to begin
with but eventually you will be able to
bring it up keep going get okay really
feel your legs working really feel happy
pumping you almost there
you're getting gift now rest next we go
back until met what we want to do is our
triceps this is called triceps dip so
you just place your arms with a clean
the space in front bring your body up
bend your knees slightly and just bend
the elbows and push it back up just very
small pulses but you will be feeling
your triceps working Thank You small
pulses focusing on your triceps good
this will give you a tone arms keep
going doing well small pulses there you
go
tighten your core try not to rest your
palm on the floor keep going almost
there
doing well you're on the seventh workout
after this get rest for 20 seconds the
next workout
back to cardio burpees everybody knows
burpees I'm gonna hit it but let's do it
okay so down into a push-up position put
your leg back bring it in jump up okay
down out in power up with your legs good
hops in pop up all right you can bring
your hands up if you want to that's it
out in power up three good
this is a really good total body fat
burning workout keep going
all right take your own pace try to do
as many purposes you can and eventually
you will progress on to do more good job
rest next workout sports still on Alex
because what we want to do is to print
lots of that for squat stand straight up
with a pot toes facing forward push your
bum back as far as you can and power up
with your heels okay so try to focus on
pushing out ridiculous and not your toes
that way you will be working on a bun
and your entire class okay
ah so slow down push up good down and up
trying to keep it back as straight as
you can and ties in your core good
so no punching forward back straight abs
tight and up with it use good job okay
good
nice view one more one more
good rest and now play okay
thank it's a really good core workout he
works on your abs and your lower back
at the same time so let's get down to
the mat we're going to do is just to
pull it 40 seconds on the elbows and up
and just keep it back straight
so no arm J or not going up no drop in
your back not going up just in a
straight line and just keep your
breathing flowing give it a read them
tighten your core really tighten your
core and feel your abs working at the
same time you will be cleaning your own
life as well if you are arching then you
will be feeling a lot more and you know
that which is not going want such as
cocooning you're doing do it almost
there okay it's not a lot now give it
rest for 20 seconds next workout still
in a plank position this is called
spider-man all right so it's really to
work on the side of your ass all right
plank position what we want to do is to
just crunch sideways bring your leg back
and crunch that's it so really build the
side of everything by maintaining a
plank position
come on guys let's work out and then
you'll be getting a fool one big breasts
before moving on to the second set good
tighten your abs keep your body in a
straight line good
as you progress same thing you can bring
the screen up and add more reps into
each workout oh what's that
let's go doing well
Osprey walk and rest good
just drop it buddy done and just ripped
it up and rest for a quick one minute
the Sun is just setting behind me I've
done one step on what I want you to do
now is to do another three more sets in
order to see result you can spin the
worker up if you really need to two sets
in the morning and two sets in the
evening but by the end of the day I want
you to complete the entire fall sets and
you must must must follow my meal plan
together with this workout you can get
this workout and my meal plan from my
website Joanna so calm print it out and
paste it where you will see it every day
to motivate yourself there is no secret
to losing weight the key is to be
committed be consistent and be patient
with your result so start now stick to
the plan and I can assure you that you
will see the difference in four weeks
time keep doing it until you have
achieved your goal to a new you renew
Fitness food and motivational videos
please like share and subscribe to my
youtube channel and website do follow me
on Facebook Instagram and Twitter to
stay connected with me thanks guys
[Music]
you